Hi, my name is Jordan Shamir with IBM Cloud
and today I'm going to be talking about Veeam.
Veeam is an intelligent data management backup
and disaster recovery solution
that is focused on providing hyper availability
and uptime for their customers.
Back up and disaster recovery is no longer a luxury,
but an absolute necessity.
Our consumers expect us to stay online,
they want to be able to access our products when they want it.
However, this is becoming much more challenging
with the rise of disasters such as natural disasters,
the rise of ransomware and cyberattacks,
and lastly human errors.
Maintaining this uptime and availability is
becoming much, much more challenging.
Many businesses have their disaster recovery
and backup environment within their own data center.
This is risky because if your data center
goes down,
you are down.
So, as companies begin to modernize,
they look at their cloud to provide a disaster recovery and backup environment.
Some of the benefits are the geographic spread.
We're giving you that two hundred, four hundred,
five hundred mile difference
to ensure availability by a different region.
Also, beyond that we provide a variety of
different economic benefits because you don't
need a disaster recovery environment until
you're going for a test or an outage.
So, within the cloud you can use the flexibility
to have a low initial foot print and scale
up as needed to accommodate an outage.
Back up and disaster recovery is completely
different than availability.
Cloud service providers guarantee you a certain
level of availability of your workloads, but
it doesn't mean that your workloads are backed
up and resilient.
Whether in your own data center, cloud, or
a multicloud environment you need disaster
recovery and backup.
Veeam on IBM Cloud is one option.
Within IBM Cloud we give you full Bare Metal
and Hypervisor Access, and this is important
because it significantly reduces the learning
curve of using the cloud.
This enables you to maintain the same security,
flexibility, and control that you're running
in your own data center today.
Specifically, with Veeam you get access to
all the advanced functionality which really
makes Veeam, Veeam.
Such as Instant VM Recovery, SureReplica,
SureBackup and a variety of other features.
It's critical that businesses have deployment
flexibility as their requirements vary by
specific applications and workloads.
In IBM Cloud we have over thirteen thousand
different deployments of Veeam.
You can either deploy on our Virtual Server
Instances, are Non-Virtualized Bare Betal,
as well as our VMware and SAP workloads.
These deployment options are available in
sixty plus data centers around the globe.
One of the really cool things as you can actually
replicate between these data centers for free
and securely.
So, if I think about backing up my own workloads,
I have my production data center in A, and
then my backup data center in B. So, replicating
between the two is completely free and secure
within the IBM Cloud.
And this really saves me a significant amount
of networking cost to have a backup and disaster
recovery environment in the cloud.
In order to meet your consumer expectation
and availability requirements you need a multicloud
strategy.
Veeam on IBM cloud provides you the control,
flexibility, and availability to meet your
business objectives.
Thank you for watching if you have any questions
please comment below.
If you would like to learn more about what
IBM Cloud is doing, please subscribe to our
YouTube channel.